what is up guys today is the release of
Dragon Slayer - so that means
everything's going crazy there's a bunch
of new items and I'm just gonna be
trying to do some flipping I don't know
that what is this thing I just picked
this up anyways I'm gonna be trying to
do some flipping with all the new items
I've already started and I forgot to
start recording but anyways the way I'm
doing it I'm going on G tracker I'm
clicking new items and it's showing me
all these items that I can flip I'm
gonna look at the profit and so as of
now I bought some super anti fire
potions - there's about a 4k margin on
them when I bought them and then I went
ahead and I'm now buying the wrath runes
to see if I can make some profit on them
so let's go ahead and check so a lot of
the wrath runes have already sold so oh
they were still selling I shouldn't
cancel that but anyways so I bought them
for 515 or 512 and I can sell them for
516 so I'll get go ahead and put them in
for 516 and that's about a 20k margin
right there these are actually not
selling so I'm kind of afraid that these
margins aren't as good as I thought they
were cuz but them for 16 K and they sell
for 20k
so let's go ahead and see if they'll
sell hopefully they do that'll be a
pretty good profit I also bought want to
be dragon bolts but the profits aren't
as high as one up for a blood I bike I'm
gonna try to go ahead and merge these
super anti fire potions for let's see
how much are they on GE tracker 35 k
okay so we'll put them in for 37 K just
to kind of see what they're buying for
okay so I already sold these runes so I
made right there I made a like almost 20
profit just under 20 K 8 15 K so let's
see what I can sell us for I can buy for
20 just over 20 9 k oh okay so the
margins aren't very good they're like
the exact same okay so I'm not gonna go
ahead I'm not gonna do that item but I'm
gonna keep looking on these crush dragon
bones let's see those must we used to
use to make the potion so I'm kind of
curious the crushed dragon bones self or
this much or did the actual dragon go
and sell for okay so it's cheaper I'll
say I say cuz if someone find you how to
crush those you can easily just crush
those and make profit on them but 25k
okay what are they sell for 16 K oh wow
that's a huge margin so I'm going to go
ahead and I'm actually
by too many because right now it's kind
of crazy so I'm gonna buy 20 just in
case they don't sell so that'd be a nice
almost 10k margin so that'd be pretty
sweet and I'll keep looking on here what
else is there magic stock - magic stock
must be what makes the Dragon crossbow
maybe this thing has already been around
I'm not even sure to be honest ok the
margin on that I mean I guess I can buy
something I don't even know what that
things used to her but just in case all
right so all this stuff is losing profit
but so think about this if you had this
much money right now you could be making
4 mil per flip that is insane and same
with this I mean I could buy the Dragon
metal shard but I come I'm not tempted
really because I feel like it's just
gonna be a bust but I mean who knows
alright I'll come back when I do
something else so I decided to actually
cancel everything and I saw that these
margins are just going up and up so I'm
gonna go ahead and try to buy 10k of
these and I'll go ahead and up at once
just to beat the person and we'll see if
they've sell and I really don't know
what I'm gonna do with these how much
did I buy them for wait that already buy
some of these ok that was quick Oh
someone's checking the margin I might
have to change that because they're
gonna one-up me
so the anti fires or no no no right here
so I bought them for 16 K and they were
supposed to sell for 20 K let's just see
if we can sell different 17 K just make
a 1 K profit for thinking I mean I'm ok
with that
so now I sold two of them let's see if
anyone buys them I will be back okay so
these are selling I guess just for a 1k
profit not terrible these are starting
to buy pretty slow ignore these flips
these are some other flips I was doing
but anyways I was looking on here and I
know I'm pretty sure you have to use the
dragon kite shield to make the dragon
plate shield if you don't just get it as
a drop so it seems like the profit is
pretty nice on that what's the buy limit
on these buy limit oh wow
okay infinity on those that's weird okay
so I'm gonna go ahead and I might loosen
my on this but we'll see dragon square
shield
okay I'm just gonna buy for the max
price 337 or is it self more and it
sells for three holy cow okay that's a
very good margin so buy these for 313 K
um I'll go ahead and buy five of them
because like like I said I don't want to
lose crazy money okay these are coming
in very nice these are these are
actually a really good profit right now
I mean what was it it's like 14 GP so I
might have to keep doing these 15 GP
actually so if those keep selling I'll
have to do that I wonder why people are
dumping them so much some other items
that I think people are the dragon
chained body I'm pretty sure you have to
use to make the plate yeah okay so the
margins aren't looking too good on this
one so I'll come back when I find
another item I'm actually gonna flip
some items that I already tried to flip
before but I mean look at the so the
sale price is staying stable it's going
up actually but the buy price is going
up as well
so I'll go ahead and I'll up this a
little bit and I'll buy I'll try to buy
20 of them these are still coming in
pretty slowly
these aren't selling so I think people
aren't buying those I guess but these
are and oh okay a big chunk of those
just sold but basically what I'm doing I
just refresh the page and so all these
have changed in the order but these have
gone up on the page I think so that's
why I'm buying some of them but I'm
gonna just keep looking and then see
what I can get all right some of these
have bought ignore these someone's
talking about talking about these so
these are buying so I'm going to quickly
try to flip them for just over 25k that
would be a few K margin we're gonna put
them in for this we'll see if they sell
none of them and these are still coming
in so I'm probably gonna pull that off
for pretty soon if they don't start
selling these aren't even selling so
that's not looking too good but I'll
keep looking at the items and see what I
can do so one of the dragon square
shields actually bought so these are
coming in I'm kind of scared that
they're not going to work because they
aren't selling for even when I put them
in for less so I'm gonna go ahead and
take these and sell them for just on our
25k
I'm gonna sell them for that so I mean
I'll still be making some profit on that
I'm making about 40k profit which is
still very nice so these have sold and
they're not coming in anymore so I'm
gonna go ahead and take these I'm gonna
buy one right now okay the dragon square
shields are coming in I don't know if
it's a good thing or a bad thing and
about this for the max price Oh what did
I reach the limit maybe is there a limit
on these maybe there's a limit on these
okay so I must have meats reach the
limit on those and let's see how many
die by so the limit must be 10k so I'm
actually kind of in the blind right now
but I'm gonna go ahead and sell these
for 516 anyways because that's what it
was selling for earlier so I'm gonna
sell this for 516 so how much money will
that big that'll be about 100k margin
ignore these items again so these are
coming in I don't know if it's a good
thing that they're starting to sell but
it sold for 337 K so we'll go ahead and
put it in for a 335 because I'm not sure
what the actual price is at right now so
put it in for a 335 so that'll be a
pretty good margin about a 22 K margin
on those so I'll come back when
something happens alright these dragons
square shields are all coming in I'm
gonna go ahead and cancel this because
I'm getting a little just a tiny bit
sketched out because I have bought them
so quickly and these things shouldn't be
buying so quickly let's just go ahead
and buy this for like a max price just
to kind of see what they're selling for
okay so the margin is still the same
that's weird so maybe I shoulda kept
buying them but so I can sell them for
337 K so I'm gonna sell them for the ste
335 K like I had before just under that
and we'll go ahead and see what I make
on that that'll be a pretty good margin
so I'll be back windows sell all right
thankfully these dragons wear shields
sold so I bought them for 313 and I sold
them from 334 so that's like a 21k
margin I kind of wish I woulda bought
more of them oh okay look at this and
these finally sold for one came hard
Janee heats cuz I
didn't want to dump them for that much
so I wish I could price check these I
might have some one price check them for
me so I can see what the my max price is
and then I'll come back and sell those
and then I'll be done
alright I have just been informed that
these prices of these have dropped to
495 and I bought them for 502 so I'm
just gonna try to dump them real quick
so I bought him for 502 so I mean let's
see what they sell for for 495 it's not
a terrible loss it's like 40k I did make
a bunch of money on the Dragons square
shields so that was pretty good but I
hope you guys liked this video I'm gonna
go ahead and end it because I'm actually
I'm probably I've done about what I
wanted to do I wanted to show you guys
just kind of what items are flipping
right now and then I kind of want to
advocate to speak careful in here
because some of these items you will
lose money like those ruins I'm gonna
lose a little bit of money which isn't
too bad good thing any buy one of the
big items but just keep in mind there's
a lot of items flipping right now so be
careful with what you're flipping also
onto each rocker there is a lot of items
on there that you can look at so a lot
of them are fluctuating like these are
going for negative but I mean if I bet
if i refresh the page yeah so stuffs
already changing like it okay so some of
it change some of it doesn't actually
but if you have a lot of money you can
make a lot of money but I'd definitely
be careful but anyways guys I'd like to
thank you for watching I know this video
was kind of all over the place with the
flipping but I kind of just wanted to
show you guys all the new items that are
being flipped and Dragon Slayer 2 and
just kind of how to do it and kind of
how to do it safely just be careful when
you're doing it but if you guys enjoyed
this video go ahead and give it a like
the door Nuala channel go ahead
subscribe and thanks guys for watching
stay tuned for my next video